In Alaska's remote
White Mountains--
All right.
Nice big mail martin.
Marty's first
catch of the season
is already on the line
after just a few hours.
This the kind of nice
because I just made this set.
It's always a good
feeling to make a set
and catch em the first
time you check it.
Beautiful.
It's a promising sign
that the follow trapline may
have bounced back,
and that the land
will provide for the future.
This is one of my favorite
spots on the whole trapline.
You can see a big chunk of
God's creation from up here.
And the neat thing
is, in 30 years,
I'm the only human
that's been in here.
You stand in a place
like this and you think,
man, if I could get a trail
cut in up that valley,
just go see the new country.
Trap country that's never
been trapped, probably.
See things nobody
else has ever seen.
That's why I do this.
God did all right when he built
this country, put martin in it.
It's good trapping weather
in Alaska's White Mountains.
Marty's racing to
complete an epic mission--
to clear and run all 150
miles of his original line.
But only 25 miles in,
there are signs of trouble.
A wolverine.
And he went in that way.
I'm going to make a
cubby for wolverine,
because there's wolverine signs
around, and they'll be back.
It's not the first time Marty
has tangled with a wolverine.
Four years ago, a
voracious predator
plundered his line
in the revelations,
costing hundreds of
dollars in damage.
Now trying to rebound from
his worst season ever,
Marty can't afford a repeat.
I'm going to use the
base of this spruce right
here, and build my cubby.
Marty's only
hope for protecting
the viability of his line
is to eliminate the threat.
Like any trap, you want to get
the animal to get to the bait,
he has to go into the trap.
So basically, you've
got something they want,
and there's only one
way to get to it.
Stopping a 50 pound animal
requires a heavy duty trap.
I'm going to take my 330.
So the way that the
330 works is the animal
hits the trigger,
which is this, and then
these springs close to the
trap, and it snaps on him.
I'm going to set it, tap it
down so it's good and tight.
There.
This line-- it's
really important to me
it's successful.
So getting the line
set is a huge job,
and the sooner you get it,
the trail broke out and set,
the sooner you can
start catching fur.
Wow.
It's different.
This is all ripped off by fire.
Marty's future
earnings depend on
whether he can protect
the line he first opened
more than three decades ago.
When I first came up
here many years ago,
this was just all
green spruce forest.
And though fur
prices rise and fall,
the land always has potential.
This can be a
good producing line.
You get this fringe of the burn
once the fire comes through,
rips through.
And then grasses
start coming up.
And the voles and lemmings
move in there, and eat those.
And then that's what
the martin feed on,
so then the martin come
in, and that's good
for me as far as trapping goes.
We gotta keep moving.
Light's fading.